[Music]
we have a long history of interns moving
on to become big Hollywood stars yep and
I'm not kidding about that it's all true
check out some of the people who've
interned at our show over the past
couple of years Mindy Kaling was an
intern at our show check this out John
Krasinski summer 2010 / they were all
interns on her shelf there's more -
there's more that's just the tip of the
iceberg so clearly when it comes to
interns I'm a kingmaker okay in this
town you laugh but it's true more
important that also means that one of
our current interns will probably in all
likelihood become a big star makes sense
yeah but why wait for them to become
famous let's introduce them to the world
right now while they're still an intern
here at the show we'll do that tonight
in our brand new segment conan's next
famous intern
these are the Conan fall interns let's
find out what the odds are that each one
may eventually be famous
okay let's start right here this is
anthony from cal state northridge
anthony's an aspiring actor it's good
he's handsome clearly very handsome he's
been told by directors that he has star
quality but unfortunately he comes from
a stable home with a good family that
gives the judges give you your chances
is fifty to one not very good
this is Nicole from the University of
Georgia Nicole's an aspiring actress she
is very beautiful
she's already landed a small part on the
Mentalist
but unfortunately Nicole recently had
the opportunity to sleep with David
Spade and turned him down that means ten
to one odds for her
this is nathan from UCLA Nathan's an
aspiring actor and director his dad went
to grammar school with Steven Spielberg
he's a level two Scientologist but
unfortunately he gets nervous around
Jews
[Music]
hundreds of becoming famous finally this
is John
[Applause]
djaq very much wants to be an actor he
can't read he thinks the Sun revolves
around the earth his current girlfriend
is a tumbleweed named Melissa he prefers
an outdoor toilet and he also would not
sleep with David Spade
[Applause]
gratulations Nicole
sorry Chum
[Applause]